Here it is. This is what they quote to
you, right? But this is talking about
what? A sin between two brothers.
Between two brothers. Let me show you
context again. because people don't know
context.
But when it's a public sin that's going
to affect the faith,
a sin in the eyes of people that affects
the faith,
then you need to address it publicly,
call it call call it out publicly and
rebuke it publicly. And they wouldn't
last more than three minutes trying to
use that against me if they were to come
up and put me in my place.
But we know they're not going to do
that. All right, you ready?
Let me go all the way 22.
Yeah, let me do the 22. Okay, ready?
Here's the passage that's always
misqued.
Okay, here's the passage always misqued.
But pay attention to the context.
[snorts]
Context. Now, if your brother sins, go
and show him his fault between you and
him alone. If he listens to you, you
have one your brother. But if he does
not listen to you, take one or two more
with you. So by the mouth of two or
three witnesses, every fact may be
confirmed. And if he refuses to listen
to them, tell it to the church. And if
he refuses to listen even to the church,
let him be to you as a gentile tax
collector. Okay, they see this is taken
to mean, oh no, you know, this is, you
know, anytime a brother sins. No, it's
specific. Why? Because unless you
believe the Bible contradicts itself,
when Peter
did a sin publicly in full view of
believers and unbelievers, Paul did not
meet with him privately,
one on one.
Paul rebuked them publicly, shamed him
publicly
in front of all those
who were privy to Peter's sins.
Okay.
But when Cphus came to I opposed him to
his face because he stood condemned. For
prior to the coming of certain men from
James,
he used to eat with the Gentiles. But
when they came, he began to shrink back
and separate himself, fearing party, the
party of the circumcision. The rest of
the Jews joined him in hypocrisy with
the result that even Barnabas was
carried away by their hypocrisy. But
when I saw that they were not
straightforward about the truth of the
gospel, I said to Cphus before everyone,
I guess Paul didn't get the memo, right?
>> [snorts]
>> I guess Paul didn't have Matthew,
Right.
Didn't Jesus tell you, Paul, to show
your brother his sin oneonone? That is a
sin commit against you if you read the
whole of scripture.
If it's public where it will impact and
affect believers, unbelievers alike, it
has to be checked in front of
unbelievers and believers so they know
this is not Christianity.
Christianity does not tolerate this.
Right?
We got it here.
We are Jews by nature and not sinners
from among Gentiles.
Nevertheless, knowing that a man is not
justified by the works of the law, but
through faith in Jesus Christ, even we
who have believed in Christ Jesus, so
that we may be justified by faith in
Christ, not by the works of the law,
says by the works of the law, no flesh
will be justified. Now, here it again is
Paul.
[snorts] Yeah, thank you, Catherine. I
was going to mention Mark 6. We're going
to show you now John the Baptist
publicly rebuking and shaming Herod for
taking his brother's wife publicly which
led to him being imprisoned and
beheaded. I'll get there. 1 Timothy 5:17
to22.
The elders who lead well are to be
considered worthy of double honor.
Especially those who labor at preaching
the the word and teaching. Notice who
lead well try to practice what they
preach. especially if they're teachers
of the word, they deserve double honor.
For the scripture says, "You shall not
muzzle the ox while it is threshing, and
the labor is worthy of his wages." Do
not receive an accusation against an
elder except on the basis of two or
three witnesses. Those who continue in
sin, reprove in the presence of all, so
that the rest also will be fearful. Is
that in your Bible? How many times do I
got to show you these verses?
You who think you're pious, but you're
fake. Let me tell you something. Fake
piety is just as disgusting and evil as
pride.
God hates fake piety. It's not
godliness. That's not holiness.
I solemnly charge you in the presence of
God and of Christ Jesus and of his elect
angels to observe these instructions
about bias. See, did you catch it? Like
inspiring philosophy says, we're not the
da gang. We don't cover up for our own.
You are to hold these commands
impartially,
not selectively apply them depending on
the person. So if you like him and he's
part of your click, like David Wood's
click, you say nothing.
Okay? How come they don't bring you
receipts, guys? May God destroy pride
and arrogance. Where are their receipts
for their claim? You do not selectively
apply these commands
depending on the person whether you like
him or not.
Right? See right there?
There's something called tough love.
Brother, when you discipline children,
it's not because you hate them, it's
because you love them.
So, how many of the clicks called this
out? The clicks
called it out. How many those who want
to be Christian and follow scripture and
how many of them are going to now show
their true colors by attacking me
personally instead of dealing with the
issue?
God bless you Benedict. So you watch it
later on the rewind. Okay, we got this
now.
Okay, we got it here. Is it sinking in?
Without bias, doing nothing in
partiality. Do not lay hands upon anyone
hastily and thereby share responsibility
for the sins of others. Keep yourself
pure. Do not rush to appoint someone to
leadership. Let me now apply that
principle in practical terms today. You
don't rush to lay hands approving of
someone being an elder. He's got to be
rigorously tested. You don't rush to
give a platform
to just any Joshmo if you haven't given
him time to be discipled properly and
has demonstrated
his faithfulness lest that person turn
and then disgrace you. You got the memo.
We're all guilty of it. We get excited.
But we got to learn. Fool me once, shame
on you. Fool me twice, shame on me. How
many times before you learn?
Can we get We're getting this principle,
right? Okay. Now, about John the
Baptist,
look at how bold he is. He's publicly
condemning,
right? Herod, who took his son's wife,
a figure with power who could kill him
and eventually did. He didn't care. No.
But John, you should have showed him his
sin.
privately how he's prancing
his sister-in-law, his brother's wife
that he took to bed.
How it's public.
Here you go.
Mark 6. And King Herod heard it, for his
name had become well known,
and people were saying, excuse me, John
the Baptist has risen from the dead. He
heard about Jesus's miracles. So he
thought that John had re-entered
another body,
right? So this tells you they had an
idea of trans transmigration of souls.
These statements tell you that some Jews
actually thought the spirit of a dead
man could enter into the body of someone
else or that the spirit of the dead man
could then
reincarnate. They had this view.
They actually believed this. You know
that. And then you find it later
articulated in Jewish mysticism, the
Kabala.
John the Baptist is risen from the dead.
That is why these powers Max's powers
are at work in him. But others saying
he's Elijah. Others saying he's a
prophet like one of the prophets of old.
But when Herod heard it, he kept saying
John whom I beheaded has risen. Now,
that's kind of weird because this gives
you the idea that he thought John's
spirit could inhabit another body
because obviously John isn't Jesus.
Jesus isn't John.
Yep. Some weird beliefs. But now, why
was he beheaded? Why did Herod behead
him? For Herod himself had sent and had
John arrested and bound in prison on
account of Herodiius, the wife of his
brother Philillip, because he had
married her. He took his sister-in-law.
For John had been saying to Herod, "It
is not lawful for you to have your
brother's wife." Now, Herodiius was
holding a grudge against him, was
wanting to put him to death, and was not
able. For Herod was afraid of John,
knowing that he was a righteous and holy
man, and he was keeping him safe.
When he heard him, he was very
perplexed. But he used to enjoy
listening to him. You caught it. There
you go. I don't need to go on.
When a sin is public, the rebuke is
public. We got that now. We can get that
out of the way. You guys going to stop
with that nonsense, thinking you're
pious and Christlike and humble and that
Jesus shines in you and he's pleased
with you with your fake piety. What they
really mean is this. No, don't attack my
sacred cow
because I'm a fan girl and I'm involved
in the cult of personality
and because I like him, I don't want you
to call him out. But if it's someone
else, call him out. Someone I don't
like, that's okay. We'll amen you when
you call out someone they don't like.
But when someone they like call the
personality, then they hold you
accountable, so to speak. So that means
right here
when we go right here and he says hold
these commands without bias doing
nothing in partiality. This is not in
their Bible. How dare you call out my
hero
Redvon or Christian Prince or whoever it
is David Wood J. How dare you? How dare
you?
Don't you know they're my idols and I'm
part of the cult of personality and I
idolize them? How dare you? I don't care
what the Bible says. Do it impartially
without bias and be unbiased. Be
consistent. How dare you?
But if it's someone you don't like.
Yeah, Sam. Way to go, Sam. Yeah, I'm
with you, Sam. You need See?
[snorts]
Exactly. Amen. So now that said, they
deleted their account. Now isn't that
better?
Isn't that better? Would you rather have
them prance on social media making fools
of themselves, idiots out of themselves
in front of Muslims and atheists talking
about, "Yes, when the time is right, I
will seek the court and yes, yes, I
accept your, you know, proposal."
Would you not rather shame them
to the point of they now don't show
their face on social media?
Would you what do you think is better
for Christians that they saw Christians
calling them out and running them off
social media that Christians will not
tolerate it and now they have to hide or
they continue
to justify their adultery aired out
without any shame.
This shows they got humiliated,
disgraced and they had to hide. Maybe
that will be the reason that will lead
them to rethink their stupid stupid
action, realize it's adultery, and come
in to repentance and come to their
senses.
Right?